all right good morning everyone for the
people in the back we have some premium
seating right here up front if you want
to sit on the first row we have one spot
left I think so
fix some other spots on the second and
third row so if you want to sit down
don't don't hesitate just come up and we
got to talk about common API security
pitfalls so this talk is gonna be an
overview of a lot of problems that can
happen in API a lot of problems you
might have in your API and a lot of
problems I'm gonna try to help you solve
in your API and I started talking about
this actually quite a long time ago
in 2017 when they added something to the
OS top-10 so the OS stop then is a list
of the ten most dangerous availabilities
in web applications and they make this
list every couple of years and in 2010
2017 they proposed to add under
protected api's to that list of
vulnerabilities some things happen in
the community a lot of people were very
discontent with what top 10 has become
and the whole project shifted gears a
bit and this is appeared in the final
version but didn't matter because the
seed was planted
people realize like holy crap you're
building all these api-based
applications and this is a real problem
you need to start thinking about
security specifically for that and
that's why last year they launched the
API security project in Ross Perot and
this API security project focuses on
everything API security related they
even builds a separate top ten for
issues about API security so if you're
interested in API secured if you want to
get started with API security I suggest
to take a look at that because it's a
treasure trove of information I'm not
going to talk about the top ten of API
security issues some of them will be in
there some of them might not be I'm
gonna talk about my own experience I'm
gonna talk about what I see when I talk
to developers when I teach developers
about security or when I look at their
systems I encounter often the same
things which is what I distilled into
this API security pitfall stock just to
make sure that we're all on the same
page I want to sketch a little totally
lava facial architecture diagram so what
we're doing is we're building an
application today it's gonna be
typically a web application in a lot of
cases a front-end so you're loading your
front-end your client-side JavaScript
based application where there is angular
or react or view doesn't matter your
bootstrapping that in browser
that's step one that moment you have an
empty shell you have something that
doesn't really do anything useful
because typically you need back-end
systems to make that work and that
back-end system is going to be your API
it's gonna be fetching data from an API
rendering displaying that and when you
perform an operation it's gonna push
that operation back to the API to
actually persist that later on we're
going to talk about the API part we're
not going to talk about the frontline
security part which also means that in
this case it's also very relevant for
people building other types of clients
if you build a mobile client or a
desktop application or whatever if it's
backed by an API I can guarantee that
almost every one of these issues we're
going to talk about is going to be
relevant I didn't count them so I have
no idea how many we're gonna cover but
that gives me flexibility to cut it
short we're running late but we're gonna
be totally fine this image is a good
starting point there's a lot of people
well sometimes you have full stack
developer sometimes you have to split
between front end and back end but off
people think about this image as a whole
well II actually only the top part is
usually relevant for security because
the top part is where the things happen
where the data is where the operations
happen
and a very good example is tinder you
can swipe left and right for looking for
a partner totally based on appearances
so it's absolutely not what we stand for
as a society but sure it's probably very
useful by the way everything I'm telling
you now is totally anecdotal because I
have a wife and otherwise she would be
very very displeased with my behavior
but as it turns out apparently you can
also see who likes you so other people
can see your profile and you can even of
course they like you the app is trying
to sell you a premium subscription by
showing you blurred images like hey
these people like you you want to see
what they look like right so why not pay
us and we'll get you access to that data
it turns out that the blurring of the
images is a front-end operation the
mobile app just pulls in the image and
blurs it and then shows it to you so of
course if you know a bit about computers
you're like mmm do I want to pay for
that no let's just spend a lot of time
figuring out how it works and you'll
find the API call that you can actually
use to get that image and with that you
can actually get the image and so on and
so on so somebody else figured this out
they analyzed the web application figure
out the API endpoints
we make the call coming from the iOS
application and they got the images just
like that and that brings us to the
first important pitfall your API is a
real attack surface it's not a front-end
yes there are some security things you
need to address in front ends but
usually it's gonna be about your API
that's where you should focus most of
your efforts when you look for security
problems and a lot of API is over expose
data not only images but just fetching
like full JSON objects and then
displaying three fields in the front-end
and yeah everybody everything else is
hidden right well not if somebody
figures out what the API calls are what
the traffic looks like they can grab all
of that data just like that so that's
definitely one thing to keep in mind
also sets very good team we're gonna
talk about a lot of authorization issues
because in security it often comes down
to authorization to preventing somebody
from doing something they're not
supposed to be doing which is
authorization we need some things to
make that work I will talk about that
later first another authorization
problem I really like these cases not to
make fun of companies getting it wrong
but to illustrate you that these are
real things because when I talk about
these things people are like yeah
nobody does that in practice like come
on you know better than to do that well
apparently not what happened here
t-mobile mobile phone operator they get
cake they can give you access to your
account you want to access your account
information is gonna be an API call with
your phone number phone number is a
unique identifier for your account makes
sense since cell phone numbers are
unique and linked to your account so why
not
the problem here is called unsecure
direct object references
it's an old problem has been around for
a while and what a problem actually
means is that if I substitute my phone
number for your phone number I'm gonna
get your account information just like
that then I figure out what his phone
number is and bam I got his account
information and so on and so on and what
they actually did check is whether you
were authenticated but he never checked
if you were the actual person the owner
of that account and were supposed to
access an information it's an unsecure
of that reference happened to t-mobile
happen to telefónica in Spain to AT&T in
the US and to Verizon in the US as well
all of the phone companies apparently
have a very similar vulnerability and
happens in other cases as well insurance
documents linked to by numbers of
identifier in the URL and then it starts
with zero zero zero zero 200 for
somebody might try zero zero zero 203
and boom there you go out of document
and so on and so on you can start
enumerating there used to be a problem
in old Web Apps we have the same thing
in api's just like that we call it
differently it's called broken object
level access control but it's the same
essential problem under the hood and
these things are really really common I
can guarantee you that in this room five
to ten people if they go look at their
API on Monday they will find this
problem absolutely that common and why
does it exist because we build
applications with two turtles we learn
about REST API is in node in ten minutes
and in ten minutes there's not going to
be any security in there I can tell you
that takes a lot longer to talk about
security but this is okay because it's
about the rest paradigm and you learn
how to build a to-do application of
course and it's about fetching tasks so
you can read a task with a task
identifier here is a request or
parameter stop task ID you can delete
tasks with a task identifier of course
you send it a delete request and it will
make sure the task disappears and when
you build a first application your first
API like that is gonna be awesome like
oh this is pretty cool
of course then you're going to think
about users like hey but I don't have a
single user I'm like I have different
users so let's learn about how to do
identification and users and all of
these things and that information that
tutorial that course is gonna talk about
how you have to implement authentication
checks like is the user log didn't know
Oh in that case let's send them a 401
otherwise go ahead and perform that
operation and that's exactly what
t-mobile and all the other phone
companies also did but then you have to
think further then you have to think
about who's allowed to access this
particular task who can read it and you
have to implement explicit authorization
checks and these things are often
missing because often people don't talk
about that and they're not very easy to
implement it's a very difficult problem
to solve and unless you go to your
application and you look for the absence
of that code you're not gonna spot this
yes with testing you'll find the fact
that somebody is should be logged in
I can access that that's gonna be in
your test but unless you thought about
this problem explicitly it's not gonna
be in your tests and you might be
missing that particular piece of code
and the cases I talked about illustrate
that this thing is really really common
all right
brings us here lack of proper
authorization always check both
authentication status and object level
access control check if the user is
allowed to access these things yes or no
and again that's not an easy problem to
solve even in a task manager like the
one that showed you here this can get
complicated really quickly I use a task
manager that I share with my wife for
example or full household and life is
basically in a to-do application but
that means that deciding if somebody's
ought to read a task means did this
person create a task lock okay that's
fine or are they part of a shared
project which also gives them access to
this task which gets complicated really
really quickly it's not an easy check to
do at a single single location in your
application that brings us here so
you're gonna get a call to a back-end
like hey I want to fetch this
information and there's gonna be some
authorization information we'll talk
about that in a second there might be
some custom headers or token in the
header something like that and then the
call is gonna invoke other services in
your application architecture and I'm
explicitly or deliberately vague about
this services whether it's a Mike or
service or another layer in your
monolith application doesn't matter
because this happens in all types of
applications there's all things involved
there's a data access layer there's
maybe a layer to a control or doing
something and so on and so on and at
each of these layers you typically make
authorization checks like is the user
logged in oh yeah that's that's good
then let's move ahead with the skull and
then maybe there you want to check all
this user is allowed to read this task
that's cool and that part does something
else based on different customers and
different projects maybe sir there's
going to be a customer specific ID check
and God knows what else the user
specific ID check or something like that
and all of these checks together
that's your authorization policy and
this is something really interesting
because if you if I had to unsecure the
assessment I'm typically sitting around
the table with five to six of the
engineers that built the application and
we talked about how to handle security
and when I asked them like hey if this
calls come call comes in how do you know
that this you
our application is supposed or allowed
to access this particular object and of
the six people are on the table five
people are going to be looking at job
because that's the guy that built this
authorization policy and Java is gonna
be like oh crap I'm on the spot now and
you see him thinking like hmm so this
call comes in so we have a token in your
requests we're going to take this
parameter out of the token and that
comes out of the database and then based
on this so yeah I think we have
discovered that's the good case yeah
this is fine the bad case is like oh
crap and they start writing like an
authorization rule on the fly like let's
just update the code to add this but
these things are hard to analyze they're
hard to audit and if you have a policy
like this were a few people only a few
people in an organization have the full
mental model of that it's gonna be
insanely difficult to actually alter
that policy you have no idea what checks
are and forced our checks are not
enforced and if these people are sick or
leave the company nobody knows and
that's why you need a centralized
authorization policy these checks are
good as a defense in that mechanism
absolutely use them but preferably you
have one place where you can specify an
authorization policy whether that's in
code or a separate declarative policy
run by a policy agent doesn't really
matter here but you need to have an
auditable centralized authorization
policy you need to be able to go to one
place in your application say like this
is what we enforce on incoming API calls
and that will give you a good idea and
that if somebody asks like hey have
recovered this particular authorization
problem for this particular endpoint you
can go ahead and select oh we probably
should add that or oh yeah this is
covered here's the policy and that's a
very good way of making authorization
checks all right by the way if you want
to grab a copy of the slides I've pushed
the tweet out so you can go to my
Twitter feed and grab a full PDF with a
lot more slides than what I'm talking
about here so that's definitely a good
way to spend your weekend reading about
API security all right or just do it
mommy
I know work-life balance you I
understand that so let's do it on Monday
that's also fine all right
catherization like I said we're gonna
talk a lot about authorization
authorization or propagating
authentication states that's essentially
what we're doing we're logging in once
as a user for every subsequent call we
need to know oh it's Phillip making the
call so we can make authorization
decisions and this used to be a fairly
simple thing to do you had a client and
you had a back-end this is the old days
this is Internet Explorer and a PHP or
Perl back end with a my sequel database
remember those times life was a lot
simpler back then anyway your
application grew you have a lot more
users maybe there was like a Firefox
user in there sure let's make sure that
works as well but essentially you had us
a number of clients and a manageable
number of back-end servers and that's a
typical application model this is called
stateful because the server's typically
keep session state a PHP session ID
pointing to a server-side session object
keeping track of states such as is the
user authenticated yes
what's his user name Phillip that's
essentially what's going on in the rest
world this is considered to be evil like
no and never ever keep State on a server
in a restaurant because we have
stateless services honestly I don't
really agree with that there's nothing
wrong with keeping state right here on
back-end systems there's something wrong
with writing stateful code actually
agree if you write code that behaves
differently based on what's in that
object that might not be the right thing
to do but if you're making authorization
decisions the server-side state that
works we know how to do that we know how
to use sticky sessions or session
replication on the server and your
engineers if there have been doing web
development for 20 years they know how
to do that and if you're building a
small to medium scale application where
you know that you'll have a few hundred
users and nothing more often my
recommendations just use this mechanism
it works of course if you're building
something like this we have a bunch of
services like 20,000 Amazon instances
and a gazillion clients this is probably
not gonna work very well and hit it's
not the use case for that anymore then
you have to move towards the stateless
systems and it makes a lot of sense but
what I see is a lot of people read about
these rest api's and statelessness and
they look at Twitter
how is Twitter doing things and then
they replicate is
their application it takes a lot of
effort to get it right we're gonna talk
about that in a second a lot of effort
to learn about these things to get it
right only to realize after it's like
yeah we only have a hundred users so why
did we do that what's wrong with our
Java session ID in a spring boot
application it works first modules to
actually do that and it makes a lot of
sense in certain applications so I'm not
saying one is better than the other I'm
saying one it's a bit easier than the
other shirt but if you want to move from
stateful server-side sessions to
stateless sessions with tokens probably
do it for the right reasons do it for
scalability not because somebody said so
that you have to do that in a blog post
about how to build your first angular
application make sure you think this
true PHP session IDs probably not
sequential and single-digit but you get
the idea this is a server-side State
server-side State lives in this nice
server-side environment in memory which
is considered to be a fairly secure
environment somebody can modify that
information trust me that's gonna be the
least of your problems you're gonna be
screwed anyway however if we move this
to the client the back end becomes
stateless which is awesome but our data
now lives in a very insecure environment
where everybody who knows how to open up
local storage can start tampering with
that information in the browser it's
like oh here's the value authenticated
false well let's change that to true and
see what happens I can guarantee you
nurse API is out there like oh you're
authenticated oh here's the data that
happened in practice there's API so you
can change admin equals false to true an
API it's like Oh welcome admin BAM just
like that of course we know better so
let's not talk about that but how do you
protect the data you need integrity
protection absolutely you need to be
able to detect unauthorized changes to
this information you might also need
confidentiality because sir site memory
confidential lo storage if you put
sensitive information there health care
information financial information it is
considered to be a safe place to keep
that information client-side storage not
so much it might be breaking God knows
how many regulations by pushing the data
into the client so think about these
things in practice we're gonna think
about that and learn about that you're
probably gonna end up here
a JSON web token a job and the tilt is
sorry for the sign language people here
the next part is not gonna be very
straightforward to translate that try to
stick with me so a job is a way to
represent JSON data and we all know what
a job looks like typically on a job has
a header a payload for actual data lifts
and a signature and we get that job you
need to want to grab that data out of
here that data is going to be the useful
piece of information that you want to do
something with such as make
authorization decisions here's a code
example of how to do that in Java and
this is a very interesting example
because I often show this in my training
courses and ask people what's wrong with
this and you have a group of 20 people
in the room and this happens generally
on every occasion
and you're looking at this like hmm
that's interesting there's probably one
meaningful line of code yet people are
like I know something I can't really
pinpoint it and it's like one or two
persons yeah I think you're just getting
the data out but you're not verifying
any integrity you don't know whether you
can trust that data and they're right
this lime tree the decode function is
simply decoding the payload from base64
to Jason well in this case to a Java
object actually this is the or a better
way to do things
verify the signature first before we're
getting the data out the result is the
same in line 6 we get a decoded shot
object just like we did in line 3 but
the implications are a lot more serious
here because the first code example is
extremely vulnerable anybody can give
you anything they want and the second is
the way to get it right and I don't
blame you Vela purrs for this because
honestly we don't need the documentation
for every function that we ever call
that's why it should have been called in
security code or decode without
verifying signature because that would
tell you as a developer like mmm that's
probably not the one I need and you will
be able to find other solutions this is
just an illustration of why moving these
things to the client makes things more
complicated
don't miss handle client side session
data if you want to call it that
our authentication state or
authorization state whatever you want to
call it I honestly don't care about the
name I care about what it represents and
that's exactly what this is about
don't miss handle that all right when we
talk about jobs for a while now why
because they have become the de facto
standard to do these things and there's
a lot of things wrong with them usually
let's talk about a pretty purple part
here the payloads that's where the
actual data lives that payloads often
looks like this I can guarantee you if
you open up Google or sorry if you open
up go I should say in your brave browser
which is actually pretty awesome
you can Google for how to do token-based
authentication angular apps and you're
gonna find something like this like just
authenticate user and push some stuff in
an adjacent web token and send it to the
client that off we go and people love it
because it's a stateless paradigm if you
look back at your very old PHP
application that we all know that you're
still running but that's a different
story it's gonna look like this you're
gonna get a session ID a meaningless
identifier you're gonna have to look it
up at the database and then you get some
vault database or memory or Redis cache
or whatever you need to get some session
data and you can make your authorization
decisions state on the server that are
it's in the database or whatnot if you
deploy this in different geographical
zones it's not gonna work very well and
this mutton the new paradigm that's
often called token-based authentication
which is a very incorrect name but
that's again not very important here
looks like that beautiful right
no more data stored on a server no more
stay to manage or replicate no we can
simply get it out of a job
by verifying the signature and we're
good to go however when you implement a
system like this you have vastly
different properties because here you
have full control over what's happening
you can control sessions you know how
many active sessions there are you can
kill a session if you want to you can
revoke access to a session and so on
here you have nothing and especially if
you use it as a session this token that
you now have is gonna be valid for 8
hours 12 hours a day and if somebody
loses that token if somebody steals that
token one way or another you're in a
role of trouble because there's no way
to kill it there's no way to even tell
application like don't accept this
anymore this one is bad doesn't exist of
course if you think about this upfront
you can build systems you can build for
example a list of revoke tokens a very
common approach like what if we give
every token an identifier and then we
keep a list of bad identifiers so we
know that this one shouldn't be accepted
anymore and you get something like this
so you have your token and you have a
list a database or a cache or whatever
somewhere with a list of known bad
identifiers so you have to go check it
every time a token comes in to make sure
if it's still valid or not and that's
under the assumption that you kept these
identifiers in the first place linked to
specific users or specific devices
because if you haven't have if you don't
have that list upfront then this doesn't
even work very well again to show you
that there's a lot of things wrong it's
lightly pushing that state to the client
it doesn't work like that somebody on
the internet called you P has been
saying that for a very long time you
wrote a blog post a very ran T blog post
which is actually very spot on and of
course people started suggesting
solutions like changing keys or keeping
lists of revoked identifiers so we build
a very sarcastic flowchart to tell all
of them that are wrong because
everything ends up either in usability
problems or security problems all of
them brings us soo-ji I suggest you read
it it's actually really interesting
brings us to the takeaway here don't
mistake a job for a session a job is
just a way to represent data securely by
adding integrity protection and
confidentiality if you want to but it
doesn't do anything it's not a session
it's not revocable and if you want to
use juts like all artists you need a
whole supporting ecosystem to make that
work that's why a lot is so complicated
because it ensures that there's a
central party in control of issuing
tokens and making sure when the token is
renewed that they're allowed to get a
new token adding revoke ability and all
of these things into the mix all right
back to a job we talked about is a few
times shots have integrity protection
they are signed by the issuer meaning
once they're signed a receiver is able
to verify whether the job has been
changed in between yes or no which is
good otherwise I could change my user ID
from one two three four five six seven
eight nine zero to something else and I
will become another person that's not
possible because of a signature the blue
part here is a signature a few things
about signatures you'll often find them
as an H Mac more on that in a second
don't use super-secret H Maki as the
secret to sign that a check and if you
use something else don't put that on a
PowerPoint slide and broadcast that to
the world again seems obvious but people
have production found production systems
using Kies copy pasted from lock posts
like a blog post explaining how this
works something like super-secret H
Mickey copy/paste production code oh
yeah this seems to work very well don't
do it why because that's how it here's
how an h-back works an HVAC takes this
input data in a jot world that's the
header and the payload and I'm going to
push it through an HVAC function a
dedicated cryptographic function that
takes a secret key as input super secret
H Mickey and spits out an HVAC that H
Mac is uniquely linked to this data and
this key and that's what you add to the
job that's the blue part in a job you
push that out to the client and
everybody's happy that's how you
assigned jobs that way you get when you
receive a job and then at the data and
the payload I'm going to push that
through the hmx function again with the
secret key and out comes an H Mac and
now it can compare these two H max you
can compare the original one with a new
one and if you're the same then you know
that the message of the job that data
has not been changed in the meantime
since issuing that job and if they did
change maybe somebody added a white
space maybe somebody's changed a zero
into a one we don't care if it's not
valid we reject it and we kick it out
and that's how an H Mac works there's
one big elephant on this slide one big
glaring problem this works perfectly
fine in your application sorry
are targeting you if you build an
application that issues a job and
receives a job you can verify that
signature very easy use key volts to put
that secret in you get it or you ask the
vault to verify that signature and
you're done
awesome however if you make friends at a
conference they want to give their
application shots they're going to need
to verify the integrity of that job so
you might be tempted to give them your
secret as well don't do that
you can never keep a secret more than
one application basically or one person
unless you kill them which is a lot
harder with applications of it people
also not recommended by the way because
hmx have a second signature scheme H
sorry shots h max are only useful within
one single isolated application
everybody else should be using
astrometric signatures which are much
more awesome but also a bit harder to
implement but you should go to the
effort of doing that what's going to
happen here is we're going to use a
signature algorithm again dedicated
cryptographic function and we give it a
data and a private key and out comes a
signature which we add to the data and
we push it out to the client in this
case and when it comes back we get a
data in the signature and we use again a
specialized function to verify that
signature which takes the data and the
original signature as inputs along with
a public key and it will tell you yes or
no true or false exception or no
exception depending on how it's
implemented and then it's the same when
it's a good a go thumbs up or whatever
that means that a data has not been
changed and that the data has been
signed by the private key belong to this
specific public key and when something
doesn't match either the data changed or
it was signed by a different key
honestly we don't care and we don't want
it in this mechanism much more beautiful
to use because this means if you are
issuing juts to all the conference
attendees all you need to give them is
your public key and the word says it
itself public key everybody can know
that because nobody can use that to
generate Falacci of tokens in your name
the only thing that can do that is a
private key which as the word implies
you keep private you store that in your
key vault and give nobody else access to
that private key and that is how you
handle child signatures and this is
the only useful thing in most
applications even within your own trust
zone even within your microservice
architecture every service issuing jobs
should have their own private public key
pair allowing you to compartmentalize
that allowing to verify who actually
generated this job and whether you want
to trust that yes or no very very very
important and again something that I
often see implemented in a different way
all right
one of the reason shots are so hard is
because they're crypto basically it's
not about Jason though it's about
signing and encrypting whenever you sign
something
think about our scenario adhere our
friend upfront which is totally gonna
hate me for targeting in it's giving all
of you with jobs it's giving all of you
a job and you want to verify that how do
you know his public key you don't right
that's gonna be a hard problem and the
same happens in an architecture you need
to get hold of the proper the right key
one simple way would be for him to write
to add is key to the wall of keys let's
say we have a wall of keys here and it
gives it an identifier like my key is
number 17 so now you can include a claim
in the header of your child called K ID
the key identifier and in the case here
it would be 17 allowing you to go to the
list of public keys 17 audacity key I
need to use you can verify that child so
if you have a bunch of keys floating
around in your organization you can go
to your key vault and ask the key vault
like hey give me the public key with ID
17 and off you go
or along a random UID which is a bit
harder to pronounce in a presentation
but realistic as implementation all
right that's very nice if you have a
centralized way to access keys doesn't
work very well in distributed scenarios
let's say Google is issuing jobs and I
need to verify them well just probably
not gonna be a very easy way for me to
grab Google's public key in a reliable
way which is why the spec has some other
mechanisms as well they have a GK you
claim and a GK you allows the issuer to
embed a URL
holding a set of public keys the
represented in a JSON format which is
absolutely ugly for public keys but
doesn't matter you never have to look at
it as a human so we're all good
but essentially here's a JSON web key
set a set of public keys I can fetch it
from there and then the key identifier
is gonna say like Oh from that those
keys just use the key with this ID and I
can now verify the signature and if
Google decides to start using new keys
tomorrow they just published a public
key on that endpoint change the key ID
in the next issue jut and again my
service can go there 50 keys verify the
signature and trust the data coming from
Google all right if you don't like JSON
web Keys you can also do the same with
certificates x.509 certificates there
you would use the x5 you claim you give
it a URL pointing to a certificate and
you can fetch that key information from
there that's essentially how key
management works in a job world this is
something that I've honestly never seen
implemented in a real world system
people think about this then they don't
do it but you need to implement key
management but you need to be careful
with that because once you start doing
that you'll end up with a scenario like
this somebody gives you a job it's
signed by a private key so you need to
verify that with a public key you can
find the key set to chase a file with
keys on evil example.com like hmm your
application has been implemented because
you listened to like half of this talk
and not the other half so it's like oh
yeah so the gku I'm gonna fetch your
skis I'm gonna find the key with this
identifier like this K ID oh yeah I
found it verify the signature oh it's
fellas awesome so your flip I'm gonna
trust you and give you access to my
account this is not good
the problem here is that you're using
information from a sign shot without the
ability to verify the signature you're
relying on this header info but you
don't know whether you can trust the job
yet which is kind of a chicken and egg
problem which doesn't have a good
solution
that's why specs that rely on this like
open ID connect have an out-of-band
configuration channel if you choose to
sign in with Google on a website in the
end that website is going to receive a
JSON web token signed by Google saying
who you are within the Google ecosystem
your account with an identifier and a
name but the application is not gonna
dynamically fetch Google's keys no when
you configure your application to allow
log in with Google you tell it that you
want to log in with Google and the
service or libraries are gonna go to
this location dot well-known slash
operating configuration at on accounts
on google.com on a fixed hard-coded
domain and you're gonna go there and
that is a JSON file with the Open ID
Connect configuration and it's gonna
have a gt3 wks your I claim telling you
like oh the keys for Google or this
identity provider I'm using 4 are 0 are
located in this specific location and
you can fetch your skis before even
having received the first token an
out-of-band configuration channel on a
trusted location because your point
specifically your application to Google
and that way you can sidestep this whole
thrusting the key thing I'm not saying
this is the only way I'm saying this is
a fairly straightforward way to sidestep
that whole trust issue something to
definitely keep in mind in rural
applications all right
enough about jobs now but I would say
it's gonna be better now no let's talk
about cookies
everybody loves cookies right no this is
a PHP era PHP session ID not hopefully
not 42 but this meaningless identifier
it's long identifiers with some entropy
in there but whatever you get the idea
that's the old way of doing things
somebody that most people something that
most people absolutely hate because
cookies have a very very bad reputation
the modern way is using an authorization
header so many applications today are
using the authorization header with
bearer as a type of authorization value
and then a token you can recognize the
EU IJ that's a base64 encoding of a JSON
object to start at least so you know
it's probably gonna eat Jason in this
case a child those are the two
approaches and I often get asked like
what should we use cookies are tokens
and I'm like that makes no sense because
a cookie is a mechanism to transport
data from a client to the server and the
authorization header is the same thing
but what you put in there is a string
it's a text-based file you can put in
there whatever you want so why not put
your job in a cookie or your identifier
in an authorization header if you want
to switch it up and people always look
skeptical with this light like what the
hell is he talking about like nobody
does that
well this is an identifier if you're
using OAuth you have a concept called
a reference token which is an identifier
to state kept by the authorization
server on the server side it's called an
access token but it's just a random ID
and if you're using OAuth you also have
the jobs base tokens access tokens
that's called self-contained tokens but
nobody tells you what to do with them
the spec is even like once you have that
token how you contact the server with a
token that's your business we don't care
about that and there's actually pros and
cons to all of these let me show you a
few highlights of things that always
come up when I first asked you he who
hears using cookies Twitter ap is like
nobody
maybe I should have asked a baseline
first who is building api's like okay
we're good it's like nobody raises their
hand then of course the other talks must
have really been not interesting I would
say but awesome
many people don't use cookies with your
abs like no we don't do that but I've
seen a lot of systems that are hosting
resources is at least in a web
application hosting resources that
require authorization checks for example
if you're loading images or documents or
whatever images with an image tag you
might want to enforce some authorization
if this is per customer or per project
or pre user you need to make
authorization decisions before giving
out that image if you don't do that by
the way you have an unsecure direct
object reference problem stick skip back
thirty minutes and look at that again
because that's exactly the problem you
have there but guess what if you're
loading an image tag in a web
application the browser doesn't send
custom authorization headers with bear
and your application cannot send that
either and let them tell you unless you
do some really dirty workarounds guess
what the browser does send when you add
an image tag to a page cookies if you
have a cookie for that domain brass is
gonna send that cookie along and I've
seen a lot of people go towards the
header based approach like yeah we're
gonna implement this authorization
header in angular with an interceptor
and it's awesome and then a couple of
months later or implementing resource
loading or lazy loading for admin
templates or whatever and they discover
that there's no information there and
what they typically do is they come up
with a hybrid mechanism like let's add a
cookie to the application for these
cases with some authorization so I think
about this upfront
same thing for web sockets opening a web
socket you type well you write
JavaScript code new web sockets
something-something no authorization
header the difference cookies for that
domain the browser will send cookies to
that back-end and that might be a very
good way to implement authorization I
fully agree that in a non web world
cookies have no place for building
something that's not a web application
absolutely get rid of cookies 100% but
if it's a web app think about this
upfront think about the pros and cons I
have a few have a nice overview slide
here of the pros and cons boats headers
can contain string based values whatever
you want
in that header key they remind cookies
only work well with a single domain
that's how cookies work well the
authorization header you can send it
anywhere completing 10 api's on 10
different domains probably want to use
authorization headers and not cookies
cookies are handled automatically by the
browser which is very good and a bad
thing but the authorization header
requires you to write custom code which
might mean you introduced some
vulnerabilities and then finally cookies
are always present in a web world
cookies are added to dom resource
loading to web circuits to cross-origin
calls with xhr if you enable that while
the authorization header is only there
when your application is in control of
that request if you're sending it from
JavaScript sure you can add it otherwise
you'll need either a very dirty work
around with service workers which is not
recommended or there's no information
there and that's the truth about this
cookies in a work world are the only
thing that worked really well because
the browser handles them automatically
again when I talk about API executing
courses my disclaimer is I have no
answers I only have options I can give
you the options I can tell you what to
look for but the end the final decision
is up to you you decide what's gonna
work for your application and honestly
in this case both of them work quite
well
that takes me straight to one of my pet
peeves security if you're riding
something with an authorization header
you are riding application code to make
it happen you are writing code to take
something out of a response from the
server stored somewhere in a browser and
reattach it on outgoing requests and one
of the questions you will have is where
do I store this thing where do I put it
like in a browser would you store things
like there's local storage sessions
stored in index DB and and so on and so
on it's like in memory maybe who knows
it's a really really difficult problem
and a lot of people struggle with that
and you'll find advice online telling
you to be really careful because if you
put in a look of storage your risk
cross-site scripting attacks if the
attacker injects some JavaScript in the
application they can read everything
that's in local storage and ship it off
somewhere else
and if that thing was a token that's
held for eight hours the next 7 hours
and 59 minutes are now gonna be very fun
for the user whose token got stolen
which is a problem and some people have
solutions like you know what we have
something called HTTP only cookies so we
can put it in a cookie and then mark it
HTP only minier javascript is not
allowed to read it and that takes away
that danger right these are HTTP only
cookies depends on where you're standing
where this is secure and not from the
outside looks like
oh yeah the door's locked until somebody
pushes that and off you go because the
problem is not the fact that you hide a
value the problem is that you're running
code from the attacker that's the real
threat cross-site scripting means game
over and this is something that comes up
over and over again people at this is a
tweet from me from last year I usually
don't go looking for these things and
calling people out but if they ask me
like can you look at my blog post and I
have some time I'll do it but I'm gonna
tell it like it is this is bad advice
because yes hiding this token from an
attacker and cross-site scripting seems
to solve the problem but it's it only
sidesteps it addresses one symptom and
that's it you're still running code from
the attacker the attacker can still do
whatever you want and need
location they can change the UI if
you're building a banking app they can
add transactions to the list of
transactions to do and hide them in the
interface users will not even know that
the transaction is there the attacker
has already won so hiding one little
token yes it's gonna make it harder to
attack your application that's true
means that your eight-year-old script
kiddie that broke in it's not gonna be
able to exploit that they'll be like oh
there's nothing in the local search
let's move on to the next one you got
away good there awesome but a real
attacker a skilled attacker a pen tester
is gonna be like okay let's let's see
what you're doing oh I can start making
API calls I can do whatever I want she
using oh I take an embed an iframe and
get a new access token that way before
it's hidden away in memory or HT only
cookies or whatever it doesn't solve the
problem so my advice is do not ever
underestimate cross-site scripting and
instead of looking for like that the
best place to put this little value in
the browser spend that time learning how
to prevent cross-site scripting in your
application much more useful because
that's the real problem not the hiding
of this value who is building anger
front ends awesome angular solves most
of cross-site scripting issues for you
look on my website I have some advice on
angular who's building react apps yeah
bad news for you guys
we react it's not really good at
preventing cross-site scripting so I
built a full full one page cheat sheet
on how to do that correctly again go to
my Twitter feed you'll find the cheat
sheet it's really available you can
download it today and start using it on
Monday at your job to look for
cross-site scripting in your reactives
if you have questions I'll be around the
rest of the day so you can harass me
after my talk as well alright I was
still good
shoot your API accept this input it's
like blah that is one unfortunate
username probably not I don't know maybe
maybe not
there's a one here so probably you
actually want a numerical value so this
is bad input and many people talked
about this in the first steps like input
validation oh my god you need input
validation I don't but I'm talking about
it now towards the end lack of input
validation is absolutely a security
problem you need to have input
validation input validation gets rid of
known malicious data if you get five
megabytes of password data probably not
a real password just saying yes 25
characters 30 characters that's
acceptable so capital 100 everything
larger than hub characters is striped
DDoS your server by sending large
passwords reject that
however input validation will never be
your full defense to the API accept this
data as input no some people say no some
people are like huh that's interesting
well it depends if you didn't accept the
first one because it was sequel
injection and you shouldn't accept this
one either because it's sequel injection
however if you're relying on input
validation you're gonna have a bad time
first of all this is a valid email
address so if you input validate this
with an RFC email address validate the
validation library it's gonna be like
yeah totally valid if it causes sequel
injection problems you have bigger
problems in your API because input
validation is never going to be your
only or primary defense input validation
can never stop things like sequel
injection command injection cross-site
scripting it can only get rid of known
bad data to keep the crazy out that's
why we have these guys at our front door
checking your badge when you come in
input validation if your badge is
missing they're being like oh you're not
allowed in here
and of course everybody with a pic the
camera and a scanner or a printer can
actually create a badge it looks good
enough to get in anyway
we have no other security here because
everyone should learn about secure
development but input validation will
never save your butt for security it's
good as a first line of defense but
never as the only defense keep that in
mind you should have it but it will
never save you from the actual attack
that's why we have parameterization for
sequel queries where we have output
encoding or sanitization for cross-site
scripting escaping for command injection
and so on
the real Defense's happen at output I'm
not an input time very very important
consideration all right final takeaway
what happens when chocolate ice cream
goes wrong now none of my kids think
this is ice cream so apparently it was
supposed to be ice cream but that failed
miserably not sure whether a different
color would have helped them with it
just any way things go wrong there's
well hopefully you'll never have an
issue but in reality you're likely going
to have a security issue at a certain
point in time it's gonna happen so the
best thing you can do is think about
this upfront like what if something goes
wrong and one of the best defenses that
you can use is compartmentalization
split things up into smaller components
if you're building an API that serves a
public part of an application and an
authenticated part and an admin part
that should not be one API that should
be three separate api's preferably
running on three separate subdomains or
domains or whatever because that helps
you compartmentalize that means if
something goes wrong in a public part of
the application it's gonna be separated
from the other parts it means you'll be
able to detect cross application or
cross trust boundary communication and
reject those requests immediately and
this is something that holds for both
back-end systems and front-end systems
and so on always try to think about
these things and reduce the impact and
you can today you can build very
seamless user experience even with
multiple compartmentalized applications
working as one big application so always
keep that in mind because this is the
thing that's gonna save your butt one
Oh a vulnerability in our front page
which is public without authentication
whoops let's fix that but if you
compartmentalize that from the other
indicated part attenti gated users will
not suffer from that vulnerability or
suffer less and that is going to be
really really important question
everything don't just do something
because you wrote one blog post it says
that's how you supposed to do things
question what I'm saying ask me those
questions and I'll try to argue with you
on why I'm right usually I am sometimes
I'm not but that's why I only talk about
security not about other things but
seriously question these things healthy
debate is useful because you need to
understand the different viewpoints and
the nuances to be able to make accurate
security decisions in your applications
alright thank you very much for
listening
grab the slides and the sheet cheese
from Twitter and ask any questions you
want to right now or the rest of the day
at the conference thanks for being here